so as already introduced I'm going to
talk about a usable AP testing approach
today using Bayesian statistics so
welcome to my talk a bit about me my
name is Nora I work as a data engineer
at research gate here in Berlin and
before we dig right into it I'd like to
have a show of hands who of you has
already worked with AP experiments split
testing okay
quite a few and who of you has already
worked with a Bayesian approach to this
visiting Bayesian approach yes nice okay
so please correct me if I do something
wrong okay so first start why would we
actually care about a/b testing at
ResearchGate
so we want to make absolutely sure that
if we introduced changes to our product
in it's quite a diverse product that our
members are not negatively affected by
it we also use a beta testing to
actually rapidly test new features on
our platform and to develop new features
iteratively um we regularly run live
tests on all different parts of our of
our website to ensure that the
scientists really find the right content
they actually need so we test new
product designs we test new product
features we look at different conversion
rates for example or we could also look
at product usage metrics we also test
new algorithms and at any given point in
time we actually run several experiments
in parallel on different parts of our
platform now I've talked a bit about how
we use a/b experiments but there are
like a few things to consider first so
I'll walk you through some general
considerations which most of you will
probably be familiar with and then I'll
make some critical points about one of
the more common approaches and then
we'll look into how we can actually use
patient statistics to help us with some
of the problems involved with a be
experiment testing and I'll introduce
the results of our library which is
still a work in progress but which will
be release soon okay
so some general considerations about AP
experiments you should really define the
motivation behind your experiment which
means you should be impartial when
setting up your experiment and not just
test to justify gut feeling you should
think about your user segments which
means if you actually optimize parts of
your product how many users and which
members could actually benefit from the
changes and is this worth the
engineering effort actually also don't
test too many versions in parallel
because you actually want to under
identify the underlying pattern what
works best for your members and when you
test a lot of versions in parallel you
can actually could dilute to see the
accept effective changes that are
running and also don't get frustrated
which means most of your experiments
probably won't yield a significant
difference between the different
variants you're actually testing you
should also know your baseline which
means you should actually define key
metrics you're working on so for example
if you're an online shop and you want
people to actually buy stuff on your
website and your test for example two
versions of a new checkout card you
probably won't be interested in the
purchases alone but you would be more
interested in average revenue for per
customer actually because you want to go
with that variant that allows you to
earn more money on your website if
you're doing that you should also
understand the range of your acceptable
fluctuations of your baseline which
means your conversion rate is never
static so or really static it might
fluctuate with a very small margin of
error or confidence interval but you
should actually look at the different
time ranges because your conversion
write rate might change on the time of
the day or the day of the week for
example if you start your experiment on
the wrong on the wrong day of the week
and for example don't let it for long
enough let it run for long enough you
might just measure the difference
between two days or three days rather
than
user behavior and not knowing this will
actually have problems with hypothesis
based testings normally I'm assuming
using an experiment framework that
actually diverts your traffic to
different versions
you can actually have you can actually
buy solutions or buy a monthly fee for
them like visual website optimizer or
you develop an in-house solution the
split testing probably most of you are
familiar with so the easiest version is
you divert the traffic 50% 150 percent
of your users that come to your website
see one version you had a 50 percent see
the other version and a new car that
they told them there are actually more
intelligent algorithms there has been a
few years there has been this nice
opinionated Block in article called 20
lines of code that will be a be testing
every single time which introduced the
idea of multi-armed bandits to actually
and I wrote the traffic to your
different version so that means without
multi unbend as you you have a slightly
different split normally for example you
could say 10% of your users that
actually come to your website will be
even in evenly split into a 50 percent
which sees one version or the other and
the rest of for example of your traffic
to your website like 90 percent will
actually see they're currently best
performing one which actually helps you
to not lose revenue while running the
test what you should also do and what's
very important is actually to run a a
experiments which is in dummy experiment
that means um you split your traffic of
the users to exactly the same version of
your website or your landing page for
example and if you see a significant
difference between the two versions
although you show you users exactly the
same thing this is an indicator that how
you assign users to your experiment has
actually liked the system actually has a
bug
most of experiment ap experiment
frameworks actually use hypothesis based
testing to call a winning variant or to
analyze your experiments me that's the
most widespread technique we calculate a
so-called p-value to see if there is a
significant difference between two
versions we also measure a confidence
intervals but to work with the sample to
work with those hypothesis based
approaches we actually need to set up a
fixed sample size in advance in the most
simplest setup and by measuring or
calculating the p-value we actually want
to control in combination with a
significance level we actually control
often we declare a difference between
two variants although they actually is
known to calculate the sample size in
advance you have to consider your
minimum detectable yeah effect you have
to consider statistical power for
hypothesis based tests English this
means often where you recognize a
successful test which is typically set
to 80% you also define a significance
level which means how often you will
observe a positive result although there
actually is none which is typically set
to a very low number for example 5%
there are a lot of sample size
calculators out there that allow you to
calculate sample sizes in advance this
is an example of Evan Miller's awesome
EB testing tools where you have a
baseline conversion of 3% for example
and you want to be able to detect if
there are five percent relative change
to that baseline which means you
actually need to acquire large sample
size for each variant so depending on
how much traffic you know actually get
to your website it could mean that your
test is now running your experiment is
not running for several weeks or several
months which in a agile development
environment sometimes is not feasible
the smaller your minimum detectable
is the more samples you will need to
collect per variant the larger actually
the true difference between your Tucson
or two versions of your website is the
less examples you will actually need to
confirm that there is a difference
between the two versions in a ideal
world you would probably stick to the
rules the experiment will run exactly as
long as you need to according to your
pre calculated sample size your website
has enough traffic so you don't have to
wait weeks or weeks to actually gain
results and define a winning variant of
your website you don't look at your
experiment while it is running that's
very important and you only test two
versions against each other and not more
than that and you're really really
patient and nobody actually bothers you
to tell you a preliminary result before
while the experiment is already running
and if you run exactly like this you
won't have any problems with hypothesis
based testing however in the real world
with significance based experiment
evaluation we calculate the p-value with
our preferred statistical test and this
is actually the probability of your data
given your hypothesis so it's not the
probability of your hypothesis given the
data because that's not what the p-value
tells you if user hypothesis based
testing approach to declare one winning
variant you can only reject the null
hypothesis and your null hypothesis will
be there is actually no difference
between the two versions although you're
actually testing for exact same opposite
of this situation
and there is no indication if your
result is important so there is no
highly significant results when you just
calculate the p-value statisticians have
been teaching people to calculate
confidence intervals to capture the
uncertainty of my measurement however
there are some problem with those
confidence intervals actually because a
confidence interval with you for example
calculate with 93 you calculate a 95%
confidence interval that actually means
it will contain the true parameter with
95% probability but this is not the same
as a 95% probability that the true
parameter falls within your interval
what it means is actually you could
compare it with you say the Pope is
Catholic but not every catholic' is the
Pope so that's the confidence intervals
depending on how many experiments you
run they actually fluctuate so they will
contain the true parameter yes but you
have no guarantee that the true
parameter which means your conversion
rate for example is exactly in the
center of your confidence interval and
the more experiments you actually run
the more it will actually fluctuate and
if you peek at your and look at your
running experiment and actually test
before it's done it actually means that
you increase the chance of falsely
detecting a statistically significant
difference between your two versions
because you actually run into the
multiple hypothesis testing problem this
not only means that you won't that you
might falsity take the statistically
significant result but it could also
mean that you fail to detect a
statistically significant result and
this effectively corrupts your test the
formula on the bottom I'm not sure if
you can see it actually helps you to
calculate how you increase the
probability of detecting of falsely
positive significant result which means
n is the number of for example variance
you test n is the number of segments you
choose for an experiment to analyze it
after the fact because that's something
a lot of people do for example we have
had an experiment running there is no
significant difference between two
versions but then you think let's look
at the countries for example where the
users came from to analyze if they
is a significant difference between
users coming from a country looking at
the different versions they actually
have shown them throughout the
experiment if you don't correct for this
and now they are always around this so
you can either use sequential testing
where you actually introduce a very
strict p-value correction that means you
decide beforehand how many tests you are
actually going to run and that means
depending on how many versions you are
actually going to compare you have to
reduce your p-value so you can't just
say if the p-value is people low zero
zero five I have a significant result
but rather you have to decrease this
value so it's very very low in the end
which is a normal that's called she-duck
correction and this is a very
restricting and you could also use a
false discovery rate which means you
control based on the significant results
you get with multiple tests you control
the ratio of the false positive results
in this set so it's a bit stricter and
you can control the error rate a bit
better and given all these problems with
hypothesis based testing we actually
wanted to find some ways around this at
ResearchGate
so we thought we searched for a method
that actually helps us to easily
communicate results we get from such an
ebay experiment setup and our primary
goal after all is even if we don't have
any significant better version or
whatever we want to make absolutely sure
that at least the version we choose
after running an experiment is not worse
than the one before okay
and interestingly also last year visual
website optimizer actually introduced
their smarts that's engine which also
uses patient statistics to call a
winning Marion and I have written two
statements here
which we think for example are quite
relevant in this discussion because with
the first hypothesis based testings you
could only say we reject the null
hypothesis that the variant a is equal
to the variant P with a p-value of 0 0 2
which would be if you can result but
isn't it better to actually communicate
that there is an 85-percent probability
or chance that the variant P has a leaf
that has an 8% lived over variant day so
that's why we started to look into
patient statistics and Bayesian
reasoning and Bayesian reasoning can be
nicely explained with this nice quote
from Sherlock Holmes to Watson how often
have I said to you that when you have
eliminated eliminated the impossible
whatever remains however improbable it
must be the truth so with patient
reasoning we actually update our beliefs
about our data when we gather evidence
so that means for example we think we
have a conversion rate that is half for
example 0 for example 4% and the more
evidence the more data we gather
throughout our experiment the more we
can either confirm or deny this prior
conviction and I'm quickly going through
some of the formulas involved with
Bayesian statistics so we first of all
have the Bayes theorem which gives you
the posterior probability of your
hypothesis given the evidence so this is
what we've learned after we've gathered
enough evidence which is the likelihood
of your evidence if your hypothesis is
true times the prior probability of your
hypothesis and then you also have the
prior probability that the evidence is
true but you can this is a normalizing
term which you wouldn't really need in
the setting of an a/b split testing so
the easier version is that the posterior
probability
after we've gathered enough evidence is
the prior probability
ability that my hypothesis is true times
the likelihood which means the evidence
likelihood of my evidence which their
likelihood of medida
if my hypothesis is true and an
interesting thing about a/b testing
especially the split testing approach is
that we actually have non overlapping
populations because if you using a be
experiment framework one user that comes
to your website will only be shown one
single version of your experiment one
user should not be part of both
experiment versions and if you assume
that this is true a and P for example
are two versions actually become
independent which means the posterior
probability for two conversion rates
given your data actually becomes a
multiplication of the posterior
probability for each single version and
luckily also a conversion rate in terms
of views and clicks is like a coin flip
model so with quite a bit with coin flip
model I mean you can throw a coin and
canady to come up with heads or tails
when you have if you show your website
to a certain amount of users they can
either click or follow something or they
don't so you have a success or failure
event and this is very handy because if
we want to compare the two variants to
put their posterior probabilities their
posterior and area posterior probability
becomes a two dimensional function of
both conversion rates we however still
can calculate likelihood which is a
binomial event and the prior probability
which actually follows a beta
distribution and because we have a
binomial likelihood function our
conjugate posterior distribution also
becomes a bit of distribution and
conjugate distributions in Bayesian
statistics only mean that the prior and
the posterior probability distribution
are of the same family so in this case
they are both repeated distribution
this is the formula for the posterior
distribution of our variant a and as I
said before the conjugate posterior
probability becomes a beta distribution
again and we can easily write this as
the beta distribution of our conversion
rates for variant a with two separate
parameters a and B which are actually
necessary to form a beta distribution
and this is choosing these parameters a
and B in an AP experiment setting is
kind of a black art you can either
choose an uninformative priors which
means you don't have any strong
conviction about for example if you test
a new feature and you implement two
variants of it and try to the users you
are highly likely that you don't know
your basic conversion rate beforehand so
you don't have any strong convictions
about how the data might be distributed
so you can simply choose for example a
so-called uninformative uniform prior
which would be the red line this means
that your parameters for the beta
distribution a and B actually are set to
one which is exactly this uniform
distribution I've also plotted the blue
line is for example where you have where
you said when you always set a and B to
the same value you can choose but all of
them are essentially uninformative
priors because the mode which means the
value of your distribution with the
highest probability will always be 0 5
meaning 50% however you can also if you
have for example the case where you've
run several experiments and several and
you actually watch your conversion read
of a different part of your website
regularly and you're really really sure
that for example in this case your
conversion rate is most probable around
4% in this case you can actually also
calculate the parameters a and B which
would be your prior parameters from this
distribution given that
you have the kind of standard deviation
of your distribution and that's given
also the sample size you've actually
already acquired so this is the prior
distribution and now let's talk about an
example experiment and how we can
actually use it neatly to analyze our it
B experiment results so we have two
variants for example we let the
experiment run for exactly one week
because we actually want to capture the
whole traffic so we want to capture a
normal week on our website for example
which is very important because again if
you only adhere to sample size depending
on your traffic either you have to click
much more data or you actually have so
much traffic that you could be done with
your experiment within a few minutes for
example if you're probably Google you
probably have 200,000 views within a few
seconds or minutes so the experiment
would only run for a total duration of
two minutes for example so in this case
we've had two versions of let's say sign
up page maybe and we have a different
number of clicks and we've acquired
total number of views throughout our
experiment and then we want to find the
posterior probability that the
conversion rate of a and B is actually
greater than the one of variant E and we
don't have to calculate everything by
hand we can also do Monte Carlo style
sampling which means we actually
approximate the posterior probability
distribution and we draw samples from
our posterior beta distribution to
obtain credible values for conversion
rates for both variants and to make this
either we can actually use numpy but
they are also very good as a very good
package called pi MC we actually have a
more advanced sampling procedure and you
will obtain a distribution of credible
conversion rates using this approach and
you can then also
the so-called highest density interval
which in this case actually for example
if you see with a credible interval of
95% then you can actually see with a 95%
probability your true value will fall
within this range which you can't do for
normal confidence intervals this is just
a quick simple approach you could use so
you use you import from numpy random you
input the beta distribution you sabra
for example in our case we sample 1
million times and then we've used here
an onion formative prior which where we
set a and B to 1 which is the uniform
distribution because we have no strong
conviction whatsoever what the
conversion rates of our variance could
be and then as I said before we wanted
to have something where you can easily
interpret the result results afterwards
so we just simply plot the distribution
of our conversion rates and we found out
that this is very easy to communicate to
other people within our company because
they will totally get there is a huge
gap between those two versions and there
it will know won't be a discussion is
this significant because we don't
calculate that in with using Bayesian
statistics and there won't be a
discussion to the confidence intervals
for example overlap because you can
clearly see for example in this case no
they don't and in this case this is for
the data I showed you before for the
clicks in fuse we actually the variant 8
has the highest problem the mode of our
variant a distribution is actually at
53.9% the mode for variant B is at 59%
and what's really nice is because we
have distributions of our conversion
rates we can also calculate the
difference between our two versions and
again obtain a distribution of the
relative difference between the two
variants which is also also clearly nice
because then we recalculate there for
95% highest density interval we can see
that
at least if we now change from variant a
to variant P we at least get 6.4 percent
relative increase which we can't really
do if we use hypothesis based testing
and we can also say there is an 85
percent probability that the variant B
has a lift of over 8% over variant a and
it has a hundred percent probability
that it's actually six at least six
point four percent increase we can also
use this method to actually work with
multiple variants and there we are not
really interested in every single
difference compared to the hour where
for example version a which could be our
default variant but we are rather
interested in calculating an overall
probability of choosing one variant
being the best and in this case we can
easily identify variant es being the one
version with the highest probability and
we then again can calculate lift and see
that we are at least get an increase of
15% and you can also use this approach
for sequential data collection which you
can't really do with a hypothesis based
approach because as the base reasoning
is we collect more data and based on
that we update our beliefs and update
what we actually believe about our
conversion rates we can calculate and we
can actually set the threshold of not
caring which means if my two variance if
there is a difference between my two
variants and it's like zero zero one
percent I wouldn't really care if a gene
a change to the actually worse
performing variant because I don't care
about a loss in conversion rate of zero
zero one percent and we can calculate
the expected performance loss by
choosing one variant over the other and
this is actually can be used as a
stopping criterion to choose to actually
decide which version to choose you can
also use the region of practice
equivalents which is again a concept but
that's based on the difference between
two variants so this is a in interval
around a null value because if your two
variants are exactly the same they will
have the center of their difference
Delta distribution exactly at null zero
and then you can define a small interval
for example where you also say I don't
care if my highest density if there is
this difference that falls within that
region and I can compare the rope and
the highest density interval of the
relative lift and then I can actually
decide which variant to use and as we
gather more data what actually happens
if you calculate these probability
distributions the more data you acquire
the narrower your distributions get and
after a certain point for example I set
my threshold of caring meaning I don't
care if when variant B or my new version
actually performs 0 0 1 % worse than my
default variant that I have right now
and you just add fuse and clicks on a
regular basis you can do this every day
you can do this every 15 minutes that
you're choosing and you can stop with
that as soon as you have acquired enough
samples which also means you don't have
to calculate you expect your sample size
in advance because it really depends on
the traffic and you can also calculate
the difference and again if you let it
run for several days you will see that
the difference the Delta between our two
versions that I've shown you in the
previous plot gets smaller and smaller
and we can see because all the both
distributions from the last slide
actually completely overlap so that
might not be a significant improve
improvement when I chose my variant
version however as we follow a Bayesian
reasoning we would actually say ok I
won't lose a lot if I change to the new
variant and I might learn
something more which is actually
relevant in a business decision setting
so with that thank you for your
attention
okay thanks a lot Nora I think that was
really the packed room so everyone is
interesting in a/b testing I'm quite
sure we have questions yes there's the
first one hello thanks for the great
talk what do you do when you have
metrics that are not binary but yeah so
then you probably have some how do you
choose your prior stare when you do this
normal yeah so if you don't have any
conversion rates and no binary outcome
your likelihood function is not binomial
anymore so you can still for example
choose a prior normal distribution which
that mean you don't have to specify a
and B for your prior beta distribution
and you won't have a conjugate prior
Konya your prior and posterior
probability distribution anymore so this
is really a setting that works well for
conversion rates however if you really
want to have more information on that
detailed I'll recommend you try and
crush curls Bayesian estimation suppose
it's T testing because there you
actually work with differences in means
of two samples so not a conversion rate
not a binomial outcome but rather you
have other underlying distributions
that's it answer okay awesome
here's another question thanks for the
talk do you have code examples of what
you showed online or not yet we will
release that pretty soon because this
will be a library you can actually use
and
yeah it was one in the back thanks for
the great talk
you didn't really talk much about the
prior and I think a lot of the power of
Bayesian reasoning comes from the park
and he's maybe say a little bit about
how to select good prior and then you
used uninformative priors but like they
limit your scope of your Bayesian
analysis and are sometimes random like
essentially assuming the same
distribution between your a and your B
which not necessarily might be the way
to go well the solution should I mean
theoretically be the same and we I mean
if we want to test two versions against
each other it would be quite unfair to
actually assume different priors for
each distribution unless we've tested
them already before if you had already
run an experiment of two variants and
then you want to actually improve one
version then you could use a prior beta
distribution and could sample actually
get the a and B parameters from that I
would argue but as I said before I mean
there is one slide where you actually
exactly know that your variant will be
for example will have a conversion rate
of 4% so you know where the mode of your
distribution is and there are two simple
formulas based on the data you data
you've already acquired which means like
the total number of views for example
and your mode you can actually calculate
a and B from that however if you choose
a very informative prior distribution
this also means you have to gather more
evidence in order to actually be sure
that the posterior disregard much more
data in terms of actually check to
actually change the posterior
distribution because if you use an
uninformative prior this actually means
that the posterior probability
distribution is mainly driven by the
data you have acquired
yeah but if you use an informative prior
you have to gather much more evidence
meaning you have to the likelihood does
not influence yet though your posterior
probability distribution as much so you
mean when you actually have yeah but
then you already know that for example
then you can use yeah okay so if you
have like already your default variant
implemented and then you want to compare
a new variant against each other then
it's actually good because yeah okay
yeah in that setting if you're
repetitive said testing sorry that was
my misunderstanding then it would
actually make more sense to use your
prior information about your default
variant for example because then you
should actually gather more evidence
that your new version might be better or
not yeah
I am very interested you said that
visual website optimizer implemented or
Anita's approach or a sort of so my
question what would be what's the
difference between their implementation
I can't really tell you what they
exactly implemented to be on I know that
they also use a stopping rule for your
experiment that's also based on the
expected performance or based on
expected performance loss and you
probably have to follow Chris to chioce
blog because he actually I think was
responsible for implementing their that
visual website optimizer to see what
they actually implement I'm I haven't
read the technical paper yet so I can't
I mean the idea is actually the same but
we do have a different experiment
framework and an in-house framework so
we can't we won't choose someone else oh
great so do we have more questions if
not and I would say let's thank Nora
again